[Applause]
can we talk about art for like a little
quick
i hate most of it the vast majority of
it it all sucks
some of it looks good like if it's a
painting like of
what's the [ __ ] of people that looks
good i'm like oh that looks good i can
see how they're skilling that
like abstract art i'm looking at nothing
a jackson pollock painting
this guy it's just mustard stains yeah
i don't get art it's just art i can just
tell if somebody's talented
but it's like it doesn't can we
acknowledge
anything to me the banksy does
nothing i'm interesting i'm with you
that's why i would never dress up like
one of those paintings
the only reason i liked and i wore that
halloween costume what i liked about it
is
it insulted the idiots that liked banksy
so what the costume was is he was uh i
guess not it was either him or somebody
had
had gotten i think it was him right yeah
do you remember exactly what it was i
think it was him he had someone i think
auction off he auctioned off one of his
paintings and whoever won he shredded it
so yeah he auctioned off a painting and
then
right when the person won the auction
there was a trigger mechanism and it
starts shredding the painting right in
front of them
right so he's like look how [ __ ]
stupid you are for liking me and i agree
with that sentiment
about him i think everything he does is
super overrated and
we like it because the art community is
like this like
honestly you know what the art community
is i think it's money laundering
oh a big part of it you said this to me
one time it made a lot of sense i really
think like
there's these four or like three uh
galleries in the world that decide who
the hot artists are and who the next
artists are it's all [ __ ]
right and i really think what it is is
how rich people
can keep money right in an appreciating
asset without paying taxes on it
so i'm gonna buy a 25 million dollar
painting it stays as 25 million dollars
i think it goes out you're right it goes
up rockets
as long as we have a good connection
with those three four galleries they
keep on saying that this is the thing
yeah you know uh picasso is not going
anywhere these people aren't going
anywhere so my thing goes
up in value and i don't got to pay tax
never about you know what they are
go they're kind of like the fed they're
def
i don't get any monetary value they
dictate money
this art is worth this much we can
inflate it we can we can take it down if
we want to
we decide the entire market of this kind
of like i don't
understand all the ins and outs of the
feds because i'm not you know they're
dictating the value of money by deciding
how much money is in circulation
and the fed and art people do that with
paint now here's the thing
at least money you could buy [ __ ] this
painting is absolutely worthless once we
decide it's worthless now i know you
guys could look at me and go well once
we decide money's worthless it's
worthless too and once we said gold is
worthless is worthless too yes i get it
i understand what you're saying at the
end of the day i could find someone
who's gonna take an american dollar bill
i could find it and i i agree with you
if i have a [ __ ] picasso painting and
i need a bottle of water
and i'm in a neighborhood where they
don't give a [ __ ] about picasso i can't
get no bottle of water
yeah but they can sell it at an auction
what if i need the bottle of water now
now you gotta organize it organize an
auction call a [ __ ] sotheby's do all
this [ __ ]
if you need [ __ ] to go now it's an asset
like i have something you buy though
it's an asset like a house an asset but
that's what i can do in the house i can
sleep in a house
i can have shelter if i need in the
house literally what it is it's a
made-up currency that i think rich
people use to exchange wealth
and then the rest of us in order to seem
like we're rich
to compensate for the fact that we're
not we act like it has value it's like
wine i've never tasted that good wine
it's all the [ __ ] same why and then
like if you drink it enough maybe like
okay this one is
moderately better than this other one
but it's one of these [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] yeah like um uh whatever
sommelier is just [ __ ] sotheby's or
whatever it's just the art dealer
i thought you were talking about the
marathoners
but yeah a wine somalia you're talking
about yes exactly it's
it is granted you might know oh it has
beans in it oh this has a little hint of
pepper and this other [ __ ] but you're
making up this culture around this thing
to create
value with you and your friend within
you and your friend that's everything
hundred percent but it's exaggerated
like comedy we can split hairs and say
oh this comedian is better because
and we believe that and we're right but
the average person's like i don't give a
[ __ ]
and if the average person was like i'm
going to pay a million dollars to go see
this comedian you'd be like you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah nobody's that good and also with
thousand dollar bottles of wine that's
insane you can still
i don't think i'm better than you
because i like this comedian and it
doesn't
make me better than you culturally
because i like a specific comedian
that exists on a smaller level nothing
like arts the whole culture there's no
elitist classes thing going on with like
this specific like if i like patrice
o'neill you don't i'm not oh you are
lower class
because and then and then if you don't
get patrice o'neill
i don't go oh you do not get such thing
now this does happen with some art
usually the unfunny people yeah right
there is that like oh you have to be
sophisticated to get this thing but
again these are people creating these
cultural structures
as oppressing tools to be honest they're
like feeding their themselves right
they're like
look how elite we are look at our cool
little group we understand things like
wine
and we understand things like art both
of those things you made up it's
absolute [ __ ]
at the end of the day what is wine and
art gonna do when i punch you in your
[ __ ]
if your culture is monetizable it's
probably not real culture
if it's if my culture is an asset it's a
bottle of wine and that's how i prove
i'm cultured
oh i prove i'm cultured because i have
this painting that's worth 10 million
dollars that's not culture
you're not culture or being into that i
feel you i've and i've
i've thought about this a lot because i
i had a bit about how i don't believe in
art periods yes
and now i'm like okay i've been to the
van gogh museum i see that's a beautiful
painting and i'm like i look at that i'm
like oh this is beautiful yes but i'm
sure there are other paintings that are
just as beautiful
that people don't give a [ __ ] about and
decided was useless these
powers that be or whatever they're like
oh this painting sucks and i'm sure
there's beautiful paintings like that
but
that's the way everything garners value
if enough people think that
that thing is good exactly so what
you're saying is right once those people
die and you can't make that person can't
make more of it then those things start
going up in value because there's less
and less of them once people buy
now what you're saying is 100 correct
right and in order to preserve that
value
the people that don't like that thing
are considered
um less than
poor lower class yes undesirable
and that's how you preserve the value
right okay so ignorant exactly right
uncouth is that is that a term sometimes
right so it's like
hey this is top shelf art and then akash
and i walk in and we're like
that just looks like splatter oh you
don't understand
this guy doesn't get it right because if
you actually listen to what i said and
akash said and 99
of all the other people they're like nah
that's just splatter
yeah then the people that we're gonna
buy it for five million are like
oh [ __ ] that's just splattered though
i'm not a liar he's just splatter
look up his paintings you feel nothing
you go to the [ __ ] art museum in new
york the modern art it's just there's
literally one that's just light bulbs
swear to god yeah different color light
bulbs and people are staring at it like
it's something so that's the thing
that's why i
and i agree with you in terms of i think
most art is [ __ ] because i just
don't get it there's some people that
claim they get it or maybe they're just
trying to pretend that they get it so
they fit in that culture and [ __ ] like
that but
classical music for example people rave
about classical music and yeah it sounds
cool but it's like i'm not gonna pay
thousands of dollars to go see a
symphony perform that type of music
but to certain people they feel
something when they're sitting there
feeling and listening to it and i can
believe that i also believe what we're
saying which is the
in all forms of art there is a kind of
little classism that forms among certain
people who want to pretend to be elite
and they're like this comic or this
music oh you don't get it you don't it's
fine it's not for you you don't get it
i get it because i'm more evolved or
whatever the [ __ ] more more class
high class but we i think with actual
art it's so exaggerated so blown out of
proportion
there is an entire culture the entire
purpose of it seems to be
classist is it different or is that the
same as designer clothes
dude sneakers designer clothes is no
different
it just operates on a lower level in the
supposed hierarchy
scale yeah right i make this suppose a
hierarchy scale is absolutely [ __ ]
right but the idea that we could look at
someone who doesn't care about their
sneakers they have stupid sneakers on
and then we could think less of them
that's what people are doing when
someone orders a shitty bottle of wine
or when someone
doesn't understand the fancy art right
you know it's even stupid we've created
sorry sorry
we've created this system where we're
like okay
the highest sneaker is an off-white
jordan or the highest sneaker is this
this that the other right
and then there's a rejection of that
which is often a return to the mean
well maybe not even mean it's like the
opposite of the with the lowest end of
the spectrum right which is like
i'm gonna wear the most beat up uncool
reeboks
yeah as a rejection of the coolest
cleanest off-whites right and but
they're both
effectively doing the same thing how can
i like separate myself
from the mainstream in order to create
value
but it's a perceived fake create value
that's why i won't wear a single sneaker
that i don't like the way it looks
i have to like the way it looks and if
it just so happens that it's made by
[ __ ] virgil
or if it's just an old jordan or
something like that okay i have to pay a
little bit more for that thing because
it has this value we all share
but i refuse to just put some [ __ ]
thing on because some people decided
virgil is good at designing [ __ ] yeah he
can make dog [ __ ] too
and to that point mark was saying that
was like oh it's the exact same here's
where it's even crazier with fashion
there can be some [ __ ] that we've all
decided as whack and then one or two
people decide it's hot and it goes from
being a cheap
piece of [ __ ] clothing brand like
champion to being designer clothes that
you can't find anywhere
the prices have double carhartt perfect
example so it's like they'll
literally they'll try to like
siphon off
value from these established companies
that are rejections of the mainstream
thing
yeah so uh champion or russell athletic
or these things that were like you
finding models that anybody could buy
are now oh why don't we do a collab with
that and then it'll become cool because
we're doing this thing that's not cool
right and now i'm going to add my value
to it again yeah everything's perceived
value
yeah yeah and i just want to put a
button on it um because it started with
banksy
and so i can hear that button on it
fashion
[Laughter]
that's good